tout de suite on va retrouver non trois
panélistes mersen diront qu'on retrouve
à québec josée legault à montréal michel
surgi à montréal bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
eh bien on est lent mais d'une tragique
fin semaine avec ce qui s'est passé à
québec et on a vu tout de suite le
gouvernement cac essayer d'apporter une
réponse d'apporter une réponse qui
touchent la santé mentale
extrait aujourd'hui de monsieur le
groupe j'ai parlé avec monsieur la bombe
hier j'ai effectivement on peut penser à
des patrouilles mixtes policiers
travailleurs sociaux ces grecs les
problèmes ont changé c'est pas unique
aux grandes villes comme québec on sait
que les psychologues et les psychiatres
ont un devoir de confidentialité mais
par contre quand il ya un risque de
gestes violents
il ya une obligation de transmettre
cette information dont il faut que
s'assurer que cette information l'oeil
bien transmises aux corps policiers pour
essayer encore là de prévenir annonçant
plusieurs venaient plusieurs millions
aussi là dedans martin et non pas
vraiment on a devancé une annonce qui
devait faire plus tard parce qu'on juge
est finalement qu on devait offrir une
réponse immédiatement
c'est un montant d'argent pour venir à
bout des listes d'attentes je vous
dirais que c'est un montant d'argent qui
est non récurrents on a vu pendant la
pandémie que les problèmes anxieux et de
stress avait explosé et le les listes
d'attentes s'allongent il ya beaucoup de
jeunes loups six ours et les attentes
alors on veut passer à travers ça mon
veut aussi mettre en place un plan
d'action en santé mentale ça c'est une
grosse affaire parce que depuis plus de
dix ans le tout les rapport de la
protectrice du citoyen parle de l'un des
problèmes en santé mentale est et ce
qu'elle dit c'est que ça prend plein
d'action qui est gouvernementale il faut
s'attaquer à ça avec plus que la santé
et des services sociaux ça interpelle la
sécurité publique c'est interpellé
municipalité on vient de voir ça
interpelle l'éducation plusieurs
départements et ça ça vient difficile de
mettre ça en place
il ya des petites initiatives ici et là
mais c'est elles ont été passablement
amochée au fil des dernières années
josé effectivement on a l'impression que
la santé mentale ça toujours est-il
dernier enjeu sur la liste quand on
parle de santé avec la pandémie on a
l'impression que justement ça remonte
dans les priorités parce que la pandémie
personnes vos biens en pandémie les gens
qui allait pas bien vont encore moins
bien
ce rattrapage là est ce que c'est
possible de faire dans un délai ou pour
être efficaces mais ça va prendre des
sommes supplémentaires et surtout comme
le disait comme le disait martin
pl je pense beaucoup plus concertée
parce qu'elles soient faudra ajouter
aussi le logement social beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments mais je vous dirais
que depuis le début de la pandémie ce
qui nous apparaît c'est que y'a plein de
gros problème dans le système de santé
et de services sociaux
vous dites que la santé matin c'était la
dernière des priorités
non non il y avait plein de dernière
priorité dans les dernières années tu
allais ch est celle d un ami des cartons
au printemps moi je vous dirais je le
sais par ma famille avec ma soeur la
déficience intellectuelle c'est
incroyable la détérioration de la
quantité et de la qualité des services
sont aussi il y aura peut-être
éventuellement un drame humain qui tout
un nouveau attaché le grelot on est
dense et le gouvernement actuel il a
hérité de tout ça et là il est poussé
aussi par l'urgence de la pandémie donc
est-ce que ce plat leurs retours aidés
bien sûr que non les montagnes sont pas
récurrents c'est un gros problème le
fait que la majorité des psychologues
soit ou privés et non au public ou si
c'est un gros problème y en a plusieurs
mais c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction
michel on entend les maires aujourd'hui
hier ça monsieur labeaume aujourd'hui
c'est monsieur pedneault jobin qui
faisait sa santé mentale
c'est aussi une question de sécurité
quand on parle des grandes villes oui
c'est une question de sécurité
chaque fois qu'il a écrit il ya pas
longtemps que montréal avait l'air d'un
piège puisque la trique à ciel ouvert te
peu exagéré peut-être mais il ya
vraiment un problème d'ignorance souvent
le convainc différence vient aussi avec
un problème de santé mentale
ça c'est lié josé parlait du
la joie social s'est dit aussi au
logement supervisé
ou qui n'a à peu près pas il ya
énormément de choses qui n'ont pas été
faites je vais pas citer la drdr
priorité mais c'est pas loin d'être en
bas de l'échelle et c'est dommage que ça
prenne une tragédie comme ça pour s'en
occuper
le gouvernement fait bien de mettre de
l'argent sur la table tout de suite ou
bien d'attendre à la non pour ce qui
devait être fait probablement la mise à
jour économique et financière mais à un
moment donné il faut faire quelque chose
il faut faire quelque chose de plus jean
faut pas juste vider les listes
d'attentes
il faut faire aspect en même temps et
c'est ça qui veut qu'ils vont être la
clé du succès c'est que si audi bord et
voici notre plan d'action là il fait
ceci cela cela cela et qu'il ne savait
pas donc à strictement l'appareil de la
santé des services sociaux je vous
entends c'est le lieu
josé oui oui et l'importance justement
c'est que ce soit pérenne là on a un
gros sobre mais temporaire mais ces
listes d'attentes le de 16000 personnes
c'est énorme rond profonde
ça va pas fort par magie puis le moment
donné où il y en a au moins ça veut pas
dire car l'europe a qui vont s'ajouter
jour là les problèmes de santé mentale y
en a mais avant la pandémie
il y en a plus pendant la pandémie mais
moi je vous prédis qu'il va y en avoir
après la pandémie aussi les saveurs en
partie à cause de ça mais pas seulement
parce qu'on est une société
vieillissante
parce que les services sociaux ont été
affaiblis et c'est donc faut que ce soit
plus pérenne que seule martine sa pensée
des ressources alors on dit on ajoute
des ressources mais non en fait on va on
accepte en partie à une offre qui a été
fait par les psychologues le par lors
des psychologues qui travaille dans le
milieu privé c'est à dire nous on peut
être fournisseur de services peut vous
allez nous payer ici avec le public
mais si on regarde l'ensemble des
besoins qu'on vient d'énumérer
je ne sais pas aussi des infirmières
qu'on parle de psychiatrie quand on
parle de spécialisation ça prend toutes
sortes de ressources aussi qu'on parle
des plus jeunes et de l'anxiété est ce
qu'on a on pied bec toutes ces
ressources là bas si c'est en fait ce
qu'on prévoit c'est faire fondre
la liste d'attenté et comme disait josé
ça prend une solution pérenne on parlait
par exemple des sentinelles avec les
policiers qui travaillerait avec des
psychologues et des travailleurs sociaux
ça se fait déjà
ça se fait à montréal ça se fait à
chambord qu'il ya un projet pilote à
trois rivières mais encore là une fois
qu'on peut on est sur le terrain et puis
on fait un boulot et qu'on détecte
finalement des gens qui ont des
difficultés qu'est ce qu'on fait après
beaucoup de gens pas du phénomène des
portes tournantes
c'est un réel enjeu et alors il va
falloir mettre en place des solutions où
on va pouvoir aller plus loin et le
parce que là on va prendre six
psychologues du réseau privé pour les
amener au public quand là là là quand la
voix se calmer un peu et que les
attentes vont avoir fondu un peu c'est
ces gens là vont vouloir retourner
travailler ou privés on voit que le
gouvernement parce que de toute façon
encore maintenant là si vous faites un
appel dans des cliniques privées c'est
difficile de vous trouver une place et
de vous trouver un psychologue alors ils
pourront pas en inventer des gens ils
sont bien sûr le chauffeur
mais sauf erreur on est c puisque le
glas n'iront pas au public c'est à dire
qu'on va le voir même à acheter ce sont
des services civils
et ça c'est une bonne solution
temporaire mais à long terme ça va
prendre beaucoup plus large que ça ouais
et puis un dernier
est-ce que j'ai du temps un peu j'ai
quelques secondes encore 30 20 30
secondes 6 mai monsieur legault ne
connaissait avec tout ça est ce qu'on
aurait pu prévenir le drame la fin de
semaine dernière
vraisemblablement la réponse c'est non
selon lui la tendance et c'est sûr que
c'est dont il va avoir des accidents qui
vont arriver et puis même jeandel
meilleur de ses systèmes de santé
mentale au monde
on va avoir des accidents qui vont
arriver on peut pas expliquer le geste
qui a été posée le costume médiéval puis
le sabre japonais la samare fait
ensemble
alors y ait des accidents arrivent il
faut prévenir le plus possible mais à un
moment donné on est vraiment dans un
stade dans des corps de santé mentale ou
et qui sont très souvent difficiles
merci à vous tous pour cette analyse en
voulait parler de liberté d'expression
on en parlera un autre jour contre un
peu plus de femmes merci beaucoup au
revoir au revoir